you know we don't know you've ever had
eyes here our fridges from the 1980s how
do you know why do you need ice then
yeah well you keep let me just because
you know I'm not drinking a vodka hot
soda I feel like I learned everything I
need to know about you guys when you
wake up and you want to drink yeah let's
go I guess I'll have a lukewarm water
yeah
okay so wait here's no note stop friend
just a friend I want to stop you in your
tracks right now okay okay
we have rituals that we have in this
house okay and what you're up imply re
tools reach rituals all right let me say
this
yeah I'm trying I'll make this quick I
want amuse this my girlfriend and i
right we love cold beverages oh but what
we do is we put it in the harness is
cold we put it in the refrigerator
can you put everything in the [ __ ]
room
yeah yeah I can't believe you don't like
that do you realize that would be a
game-changer also like proper food yeah
you know whoa dude I don't like the way
you said that ha ha ha yes she's Asian
dude she's just mixed with a little bit
of French say the other part Bobby
she's have Egyptian Filipina I love
Egyptians I'm Adam ed shoutout to you my
friends wherever you are whenever desert
you're hanging out in right now he's in
the Middle East by the way I'm not
saying that as a racist he's actually
out in Abu Dhabi or something so
whatever does your name it's not a
racist thing god bless you and take care
okay
this should be an interesting cocktail
that's a moment to go to my sister's
house and get ice
is it far she's a block away you know
I'll turn another thing is is that we
just don't use ice because I don't drink
you know that right
no but you drink fluids yeah yeah but
you know we say what we do is this okay
just hear me out okay what we do is we
buy a bottle of water like this okay
yeah and then we stick it in the
refrigerator the refrigerator I don't
know how it works but I start making ice
maybe yeah it chills are you sure that's
in there we haven't made ice in five
years yeah do you understand yeah but
half of your listeners right now we're
going hold on you guys don't have I eat
like that's like it when we finally get
it it's it feels like such a treat like
when I go to my go get to my sister's
house my the first thing I go to is
they're crushed ice ice mr. ice machine
yeah I can't even say that delicious
thing ever and I sit there and I just
crunch ice for like hour oh yeah yeah
yeah you know you can have that every
day right where do we get the one what
do you mean no is there a machine that I
can buy yeah yeah Bobby there is yeah
actually I bought all of them I love ice
I've had an I've had like three
different ice makers yeah I'm thinking
about getting one installed in my garage
uh-huh cuz I want the hardcore like the
crush ice what it is it what is this is
that what I'm saying is is that I know
when you put ice and things it waters it
down or it makes it cold okay I can't
believe I can't believe I got a drink
this quickly yeah I'm gonna get [ __ ]
hammered on these podcasts I'm trying to
yeah yeah you say this okay next time
you come over I'll bring you my oh no no
no no I don't trust you oh I got the
challenge can we say this right now I'm
a man of my word okay everyone back up
all right let me say this right now
[ __ ] you will have varieties of
ice like ice with different like cold
grapes Oh
ya know you or water ice maker cubes the
tray dude do we get one of those you
don't even have ice maker trays if we
had ice maker tray with me guys [ __ ]
nice but it's the old one they are that
fridge over these are top regularly
what's cold in there something there we
might have something there yeah yeah
blueberries how old are these
blueberries uh they're pretty new buddy
new yeah they might be a little
frostbitten though yeah yeah okay you're
gonna put frozen blueberries in there or
something dude knows that frozen cooler
oh my god this is why he would've been a
race Wars oh my it's as cold as all
right and flavored all right enjoy your
beverage
[Music]